I'm going to change the world just a little bit Michael. Okay,
that last one was really easy, and it was easy for
a bunch of reasons, but one of the reasons it was
easy is that every time it took an action it did
exactly what you expected it to do. Now I want to introduce
a little bit of uncertainty, or stochasticity into the world. So,
let me tell you exactly what that means. When you execute
an action, it executes correctly, with probability of 0.8. So 80% of
the time, if you go up, it goes up. Assuming you can go up. If it goes, if you
say down, it goes down, assuming you can. Left,
it goes left; right, it goes right. Got it? Yeah!
>> Now, 20% of the time, the action you take actually causes you to
move at a right angle. Now, of course, there are two different right angles you
could go to, if you go up, you could go either left or right at
a right angle. And so that 20%
gets distributed uniformally. Okay? Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, I think so. And so if you, if you're in the start state and you try
to go up, then there a 10% chance that you tend to bump into the wall.
>> Yes.
>> And then you just stay where you are I guess.
>> Right. So if you, if you decide that you'd have x
here, you have a 80% chance of moving up, you have a 10%
chance of moving to the right. And you have a 10% chance
of moving to the left but, of course, you'd bump a wall and
you would end up right back where you started. Got it?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, good.
>> So, here is my quiz question for you Michael. You recall, we came up
with two sequences and the one that I decided to keep was up, up, right, right,
right. My question to you, is, what is the reliability of the sequence, up up,
right right, actually getting you from the start
to the goal, given these probabilities, this uncertainty?
>> And so,
we're just going to try that sequence, and ask whether
or not it actually got us to the goal.
>> Exactly. And when I say, reliability, I really
mean, what's the probability of it actually succeeding? Interesting. Okay.
>> Alright. So let's see if we can figure out the answer. You're ready?
>> I'm ready.
>> Alright. Go!